Guys, you ever see
a photo in the news and think,
"That headline
could be much better"?
Well, I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for
"News and Improved."
[ Applause ]
-♪ News and improved ♪
-For example, check out
this first photo here.
The original headline was,
"Biden Signs Executive Order."
That headline
can definitely be improved.
'Cause if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Check out this next photo here.
The original headline was,
"Warren Attends
Senate Confirmation."
But if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, that's crazy."
Up next, this headline says...
Headline could have been,
"Britain's Health Secretary
Announces, 'It's-a me, Mario!'"
[ Laughter ]
Pretty big announcement.
Next headline was, "Boris
Johnson Unveils School Program."
[ Laughter ]
Headline could have been...
I'd watch that.
I'm excited for that one.
Up next, this headline says,
"Djokovic Wins Australian Open."
Headline could have been...
It's a beautiful thing.
Next headline was,
"Biden Addresses Economy."
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter ]
What? The headline
could have been that?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Deer scat."
This next headline was,
"Spring Training Kicks Off."
Headline could have been...
That is all the time we have
for "News and Improved."